what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything marvel cinematic universe and
if you aren't excited for the future
of the mcu you better get excited
because in this
video i'm going to be going over 25
new mcu projects all of which are coming
out within the next couple of years
i'll be going over their release dates
where they are currently right now in
production and when to expect
their first teaser trailer and full
trailer we have a lot of projects to
talk about so let's get started but if
you love marvel be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news
also the captain america shield giveaway
ends this friday so be sure to check out
those details in the description down
below
now obviously one division was the start
of marvel's phase four however it wasn't
supposed to be
black widow was supposed to be the first
marvel project of phase four but we know
how that went
it got delayed several times including
yesterday so one division kicked off
marvel's phase four
and obviously right now we are in the
middle of streaming the falcon and the
winter soldier so the next project that
we'll be getting from marvel studios is
going to be
the loki series last week marvel
released their first
official poster for the loki series
stating that it comes out on june 11th
of this year
now marvel studios has already released
the first teaser trailer for
loki and they released the first
official full trailer for loki at
disney's investor day last year
but as the falcon and the winter soldier
comes to an end in about a month and a
half
that's when you can start expecting one
or two more full-length trailers but of
course a lot of those tv spots that
we're used to seeing
and then of course after loki we have
black widow with its new release date of
july
9th of 2021 black widow is now going to
be released simultaneously on disney
plus
and in the theaters at the same time it
will be on disney plus premiere access
and you will have to pay 29.99 to get
the movie
now we've pretty much gotten all of the
trailers for black widows since it was
supposed to be released about a year ago
so when we start getting new trailers
they're probably going to be old
trailers with
a clip or two of new footage and we can
probably expect those around may
and june then after black widow we have
marvel's animated project
marvel's what if now marvel has not
released a specific
release date for this project but they
did say that it is coming out in summer
of 2021
after black widow and it's going to be
coming out before
xiang chi so it's most likely going to
be coming out in august of this year
much like the other projects we've
already gotten a teaser trailer for it
and a full trailer as well but coming
june and july we'll get another full
trailer for it along with some tv spots
as well
and then as i mentioned after marvel's
what if comes xiang chi and the legend
of the 10 rings
this release date just got pushed back
to september 3rd
of this year 2021. now we actually
haven't gotten a trailer for
shanghi yet but seema leo who is going
to be playing the role of xiangxi makes
it very clear that he wants to release
the trailer
now unfortunately it's not up to him
it's up to the studio but assuming this
phase 4 schedule sticks to the same
schedule and there are no more delays we
can expect it around
april or may and that's just for the
teaser the actual full-length trailer
will come a few months after the teaser
releases
then we have marvel's eternals which is
going to be releasing on november 5th of
2021 this year
now the teaser for the eternals has been
done for some time now but unfortunately
it's got delayed a few times as well
they actually showed some footage a year
ago at ccxp
and since then we've been patiently
waiting for the trailer to pop
up but unfortunately given this schedule
we probably aren't going to be getting
the teaser until june or july of this
year
and of course the full-length trailer
will come out a few months after that
now we dive into the marvel projects
that have not yet been completed as far
as filming is concerned
after the eternals comes miss marvel and
the hawkeye series
both right now are currently filming and
there are many photos out there
and videos out there right now showing
behind the scenes footage
now marvel has not yet mentioned a
specific release date for miss marvel or
hawkeye but
they have stated that both are coming
out in late 2021
now given the fact that the eternals is
going to be released in november and
spider-man no way home is going to be
released on december 17th
miss marvel is most likely going to be
released in october
or november which means the hawkeye
series will most likely be released in
november or december
and that's going to be a very crammed
year at the end of 2021 that will be
10 marvel studios projects that have
been released in one
year starting with one division and
ending with spider-man no way home
which is great news after coming out of
2020 with no marvel projects released
whatsoever
now the first teasers for miss marvel
and hawkeye are most likely going to
come around august and september
maybe a little bit earlier depending on
the actual release date
and of course we cannot forget the very
last film of 2021
spider-man no way home coming out
december 17th
now they are currently filming
spider-man no way home and we
kind of got a little teaser but it's not
an official teaser trailer we just got
the title
the first teaser trailer could probably
be expected somewhere around
august sony and marvel studios like to
release teaser trailers about five or
six months before the actual movie
releases
then kicking off 2022 is doctor strange
in the multiverse of
madness this is currently filming as we
speak and has a release date of march
25th of 2022. we can expect the first
teaser trailer for this around november
of this year
perhaps even a post-credits scene and
spider-man no way home as doctor strange
is going to play a pretty significant
role in that film
mentoring peter parker then after doctor
strange comes thor
love and thunder currently scheduled for
may 6th of 2022
this is currently filming and we've seen
many leaked photos within the last
couple of weeks and this movie is
definitely going to be exciting
especially with
jane foster becoming thor the first
teaser for thor love and thunder is most
likely going to come out in december
of 2021 or january of 2022
then after thor love and thunder comes
black panther 2 and despite the
unfortunate passing of chadwick boseman
marvel studios still has a planned
release date of july 8th
of 2022 the first teaser trailer for
black panther 2 will most likely come
in february or march of 2022 then we
have captain marvel 2 which is currently
in pre-production it is scheduled right
now for november 11th of 2022. the first
teaser trailer for captain marvel 2
should be expected around june or july
of 2022
then we have she-hulk and moon knight
which are currently in pre-production
and scheduled to release sometime in
2022 but marvel studios has not given a
specific
release date yet but these will most
likely come in the beginning half of
2022
which means secret invasion and iron
heart should be coming in late
2022. right now marvel studios seems to
be doing four movies and four disney
plus projects in one year which is a ton
of content
so teaser trailers for she-hulk and moon
night should be expected around the end
of 2021 and the beginning of 2022
with secret invasion and iron heart
trailers to be expected around mid-2022
and then we have the guardians of the
galaxy holiday special which we can
assume is going to be coming in december
of 2022 since marvel did say it is
coming out
late 2022. i'd be shocked if it didn't
come out in december
now this is going to be a little bit
different since it's a holiday special
we're not sure if it's going to be just
a one episode type of deal or a few
episodes but regardless the teaser
trailer for this is most likely not
going to come out until november of 2022
right before the holidays
and then for 2023 we don't actually have
specific release dates but we do have
official movies announced for that year
at disney's investor day kevin feige
announced ant-man
quantum mania guardians of the galaxy
vol 3
blade which of course he announced at
san diego comic con of 2019
he also announced the fantastic four as
well back in 2019 and then again at
disney's investor day
andy also announced armor wars then we
have deadpool 3 which is kind of
unofficially announced ryan reynolds has
announced it in interviews and kevin
feige has announced it in interviews as
well
but we don't have an official release
date it should be coming however
in late 2023 or early 2024
and then we have the i am groot show
coming to disney plus that is most
likely going to be a 2023 project as
well
now as far as these trailers are
concerned we don't have official release
dates so it's pretty hard to guess
but marvel studios likes to release
teasers about 6 months before
now since ant-man quantum mania has
begun production
it's most likely going to be the first
project of 2023 so we can most likely
expect that first trailer mid 2022
and there you have it all marvel studios
upcoming projects from now
to 2023-2024
and like i said you should be excited
because marvel studios is releasing a
lot of different movies
and disney plush shows within a span of
just two to three years we will most
likely get all of these movies and shows
before the end of 2023
that's 25 different projects in two
years so a lot to be excited for and i'm
going
to be covering all of these different
movies and shows so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos
and in the meantime let me know in the
comments down below which marvel
projects you are the most
excited about leave your thoughts down
below don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter don't forget about
the shield giveaway you can find the
details in the description down below
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you